[Music]
hi everybody i'm josh welsh president of
film independent and welcome to a
very special evening with malcolm and
marie
um i'm so excited to have the chance to
talk with the filmmakers behind this
incredible new film
it's coming out on netflix on february
the 5th um but if you're watching this
you've presumably already seen the film
uh through an advanced link and um
really really excited to dive into it
before we get started um i just i want
to thank a couple people
um first and foremost the hollywood
foreign press association
who's the lead funder of film
independence year-round programming
thank you to everyone at the hfpa we
love you guys um
and then uh equally huge thanks to
netflix for making
uh tonight's conversation and the
screening possible
uh we love you too everyone at netflix
um
so with that um this is a huge honor
tonight we have the writer director sam
levinson
we have the cinematographer marcel rev
and we have the cast of this film
the entire cast andea and john david
washington
thank you all for being here incredible
to have you thank you
thank you thanks for having us yeah
thank you so
i have so many questions about this film
how it was made and the the trajectory
and and
the just everything about it um but i
mean let me just start by saying it's a
beautiful film it's
i mean tour de force performances
incredibly emotionally engaging
beautiful writing uh and the
cinematography
uh is luminous and beautiful black and
white
shot on film is my understanding so love
to
get into that in a little bit um but sam
maybe to start with you just i'd love to
hear
so i know that this was this phone was
shot during the pandemic
but i'm curious what was the origin of
the film is this an idea that you've
been developing
pre-covet or was this something where
the writing also happened
more recently no so we were we were shut
down
uh a day before shooting
season two of euphoria um because of the
pandemic so
we all kind of went back home and
throughout that process
you know just being shut down you know z
and i would spend a lot of time on the
phone talking
you know what are we gonna do with
season two should we you know should i
rewrite it
what's gonna happen when are we coming
back and then at some point i think she
said well
like i don't know you know when's this
gonna end i'm
is a little i'm a little bit more
pessimistic uh
about you know about what the the future
holds and she was like well can we just
shoot a movie
in in my house so then i just started
kind of throwing out
completely insane ideas to her
like what happens if we just do a movie
and you wake up and you're like having a
psychotic break and you still think
you're on casey undercover and you're
you know and and she's like uh
i don't know about that sam and then
finally
you know you know at the same time i was
talking to
to marcel and and to and to ash and i
think we felt a certain responsibility
to if that if to see if we could if we
could make a movie safely
where could we do it how can we get our
euphoria crew who
is truly our family back to work
um and how and and you know and is there
a way
that we can in this time where it seems
like everything is impossible
can we just tell a story of with two
people and one location
and so we kind of it's it was odd
because we sort of had to reverse
engineer everything uh into it we had uh
we we knew that it was gonna be one
location two actors so
from that point on i thought well what
if it's just a relationship piece
and then i i i looked at my wife ash
who's also a producer
on this movie i said what if it's about
a director who forgets to thank his
partner at a movie premiere
and she just burst into laughter because
maybe that was something that i had once
done in my life granted
the trajectory of that was not uh the
same as malcolm and marie's but
we only had a conversation about on the
car ride home but it sparked a lot of
you know thoughts in me about what
happens when you don't acknowledge the
people
that that make something possible and
make you
a better artist a better you know human
being
and and so i i called z i said z what
about this idea she's like i love this
idea
what happens and i was like well i don't
know and so
and so i just started kind of writing
and as soon as i started writing
i knew i was running for z and but
but i was also writing z in a way that i
i know her to be not what she's playing
on euphoria which is
a very strong funny
uh confident
tough doesn't mind a little bit of a
doesn't mind scrapping a little bit
you know um and just uh you know woman
and i thought
i thought okay i'm gonna write this but
i thought well who can go toe-to-toe
with her
because you know it's this this is gonna
be like a 12-round fight
and the only person who came to mind was
john david washington
and i've met john david you know a
couple of times but
you know i've worked with his sister
claudia washington on a number of
projects before so i knew him enough to
cold call him
and um so cole called him i said would
you be interested
i had written like five eight pages at
that time
i said he said well what's the movie i
said i don't know but i got five or
eight pages let me read them to you
and he was like all right well this
sounds good but like keep me posted you
know and so
so at that point i just started i just
started writing and it
and there was no structure to it there
was no kind of general idea i knew it
was an argument and it would end with
with just marie turning out the light
and
and that was that they go to sleep and
so out of that
um just knowing that i think i sat down
i just tried to write this kind of
socratic
dialogue in a way where one character
stakes a position
and then the you know the other
character just challenges it and
out of that we start to dig deeper into
their
relationship into their work into how
they view one another
whether you know what their grievances
are their resentments
and in the hopes that we could arrive at
something that felt
you know universal and uh and
and true and that was basically
kind of how how it came about so you
literally were writing it in the spring
of 2020.
i started writing it in april and then
as i was writing
we were you know kevin turin uh
uh ashley um claudia everyone was
looking at covid you know protocols
talking to epidemiologists scientists
and we just we just started to kind of
put things on credit card
so my producer kevin called me he's like
you know
uh sam you better finish the script
because i just put like 80 000
worth of black and white kodak film on a
credit card so
and you know it just so you know it
became
more and more imperative that we
actually pull this thing off
and uh and we and we do it uh and we do
it safely
i have to say that's amazing to hear
that that that's how it came about
because the script feels
lived in in a sense like that it's a
relationship that has a history
they go deep talking to each other in in
their fight
but it feels like th the the themes that
are talked about in the sense of history
it just feels
it's so rich and feels like
and some of the conversation i don't
know i mean i'm sure some of this has
been percolating with you for a while
but
some of the things that they talk about
feel like
it's amazing to hear that you that this
really was written
in april onward yeah i mean
i think look that's a testament i think
to the performances it's also a
testament to
i think you know john david and zendaya
aren't just actors they're producers on
this
so you know we would go through every
single line of dialogue what does this
mean
what's he talking about what was this
relationship how does this work and we
really
just we got into the specifics of all
that and because it wasn't a normal
production
where people are you know coming up and
saying you know sam marcel what do you
think of this wallpaper and should we go
look at this location
it was just there was nothing there was
no first a d there was no script
supervisor
there was we had a crew of 22 people
quarantined
on a ranch in separate units and we just
sat in a parking lot and hashed all of
it out
i think i had two-thirds of the script
when we first got up there
i didn't know how it ended i didn't know
where it went i didn't know what
really the movie was even about and it
was only out of our conversations
that something started to kind of form
and more and more life just seeped into
it
and and then you know uh and the
discussions that we had about our own
experiences about how we felt about
things that all just seeped into the
into the piece and then i think the day
before shooting
i i sat well i sat down with kevin katia
harrison kicked around some ideas went
sat down wrote wrote another 25 30 pages
came back to
jd z we all talked it out we started
shooting the next day
wow amazing amazing i'm assuming
none of you have made a film in this way
before right this is a first
yes so john david and zendaya i'd love
to hear from you like when you got that
script whether the two-thirds script or
the full script
like what was your initial um
approach to this like how did you start
working together the two of you
before the camera started rolling did
you have any time just to
spend together to develop a relationship
before the filming started or how did
that go
um we never really had a full script
um the way you know it kind of
happened was you know sam would write
you know a few pages at a time and then
he'd call me and read them aloud
and then we talk about them for like
what max five hours but
it depends on the day um so you know
you know he we uh so i always
i kind of got it we got it in sections
you know so it's like
we talk and then you know he he would um
you know we'd leave on a cliffhanger or
i'd be like well she can't come back
from that why
why would why would why would great sam
great you know like why would you give
make her be that or say that or whatever
the case may be you know
and i was like you know and then and
then it became this you know
now i'm like taking taking marie
personally now because i know
that not only was she written for me
about a lot of ways she was written to
me
meaning i think you know these
characters
you know represent like this where i
also emotionally impeded i think as a
young actress and i think
you know that was very much um in sam's
mind and i'm grateful that we've had now
this history of being able to create an
entire show together where we
have talked a lot about any and
everything you know there's nothing ever
off the table and so
all of that i think also feeds into
these these characters and and marie was
already kind of forming and existing and
then becoming very personal to me so
once you know once uh we we started
talking then i was like okay
well uh well i think she should say that
you know and
he'd say i'm like no i don't know if
that's the right you know like there
becomes this like battle of like you
know digging these characters into these
holes and then
seeing how we're going to dig them out
you know so that was fun for me
because every day you just uncover
something new
you know and i've never been a part of a
a script from its inception
you know like literally i got to watch
every page just come to life
you know and i would record uh sam's
sam's um
uh his reciting uh
of of words which was quite interesting
and fun
um so with that with that kind of
already happening
it was it was special in that way and i
and i remember when
sam told me he was first um like
if he thought like he could uh cold call
john david washington and i was like
you think he'd like you think he'd do it
you know because that would be that
would be our dream
you know that was like the the the dream
um the dream and and hopefully he would
he would say yes to eight pages
you know um so i was like anxiously
awaiting
you know what what what he what the
response was gonna be you know i was
like please call me immediately you know
and um uh i don't know if it was a firm
yes i didn't hear
like sam didn't tell me he's definitely
in he just said he asked some wonderful
questions and
that's when i was like oh he's he's the
real deal
you know because i knew i heard through
sam you know he was already asking
questions that hadn't even been
nothing had been written yet to answer
the questions
so it was amazing that those questions
were asked because it already informed i
think and helped sam
um and myself navigate where this was
all gonna go so he was already kind of
um
actively being a producer before he even
just
truly gave gave us a yes you know
so it was it was really special to kind
of watch and then when we all got
to kind of meet together and be together
in the same space it was
these is this group of people right here
on this
on this call in a in a in a big
conference room
just uh hashing it out for like
how many days like 12 days of just like
non-stop every day hours on end
going through the material and
questioning everything and having
conversations and
and once you know we'd get into a scene
and we'd start talking and it would be
like okay and then you know
go into discussions about love and
relationships or whatever and then
somehow segue into now
the the three of them are having a
hip-hop conversation and and i'm just
like
learning you know sitting back and
watching it unfold you know
it was it was so fun because it and then
it would somehow go back into
industry and our experiences in industry
and everybody's you know talking about
that so it just
it really was a special kind of um i
mean
you know collaborative effort i say that
because it's a line in this in our movie
but it really
it really was a special unique kind of
kind of thing david what so you got
seven or eight pages of this what
what in those pages made you think this
is really interesting i want to
pursue this uh it might have been the
way he was
sam can connect i think it might have
been the way he was reading it
you know i was just getting blitzed with
feelings it was feelings of clock
all over the place and some of the and
some of the sub
of the subject matter was felt it was it
was
um it was terrifying which is what i
really got excited about um honestly
though i i
i knew i was in he didn't need to read
me anything he didn't even see me i was
going to do it you know the the prospect
of working with zidane sam marcel what
they're doing on euphoria
is groundbreaking and uh people are
still still catching up to it so i'm
like
at the you know the opportunity to work
with them it was all good let's go for
it and uh getting to say these words um
i i got a great deal of anxiety i got
very nervous because i wasn't hearing a
lot of stage direction i was hearing a
lot of dialogue you know
and some monologues and reading it i was
like oh my god explosive
it was jumping off the page so um you
know i just and like today i said like
once we got in the thing tape and got to
know everybody
um i realized that they were the real
deal like the subjects that kept
being brought up i mean marcel put me on
a lot of like
we were talking about wu tang right and
like who's the best emcee and
and all this stuff i was getting from
him was was so interesting to me because
it made me feel like oh he's going to be
able to capture my rhythm
he's going to know he's going to know
all the the freedom that they're giving
me
is going to it's going to be useful it's
going to be used they're
they're really embracing this this uh
this unity
um so this group that that was assembled
so i was excited about it truly
that's great i have to say that when you
talk about feeling anxiety over it
as an as someone watching the film like
from the first scene
i was anxious like in the best way right
where you're
i mean the film starts it's like out the
gate like a
shot i mean you john david is like you
come in you are amped up you are going
and uh well i could i can if i can
i can relate to that though like i uh
where i remember
uh meeting sam and ashley at a sun at my
sundance premiere
like i know what it's like to i need the
film to do well at sundance i've been in
cannes i needed
i got you know naomi campbell uh
christopher nolan
and and uh uh and all these people like
sitting in front of me like if this
doesn't work
my career is over you know so i know
that anxiety that pressure and then that
feeling that weight
that's lifted when it does go well which
is where we find the characters or at
least one of the characters
uh in this celebration celebratory very
you know
hyper hyper mood so i can relate to that
um so i also i question for sam and
marcel
is the decision to shoot on both black
and white and to shoot on film
when when in the process did you make
that decision and sort of what drove
that
um i think pretty early on um
you know i i remember talking to talking
to marcel about it
and talking to z about it we knew we
wanted to shoot on film
because i think we wanted part of what
we were trying to do is can we make
something
cinematic given the limitations that we
have you know
small a smaller crow um
anything so film was always was always
on the table and then black and white
was sort of an instinct and then i think
as marcel and i started
to kind of look at different references
um from
lenota to joseph losses the servant to
virginia woolf um we just started to
notice that
every single actor in those movies
uh was white and you know
by the time black actors started to get
opportunities in this
in in hollywood black and white film had
fallen out of fashion
and and granted there's black directors
who've you know sort of reclaimed that
from spike lee to charles burnett
um uh but you know so it's not it's not
a new
or or original idea in in that sense but
but because this was a story about
hollywood
because it was about the industry it
felt interesting to kind of
reclaim that sort of golden age of of
cinema kind of narrative
and frame these two characters um within
it and the iconography of it and the
timelessness of it
because i think that's that's ultimately
where we want to see the business moving
[Music]
so marcel i'm curious specifically a
decision to shoot on film rather than
digital um
i'm curious like were you doing a lot of
long takes like the scenes very i mean
the whole thing is
just plays out over this long period of
time but
were you doing long takes letting them
go or because you were shooting on film
was it a little more
tighter in your your shooting style i
mean uh technically speaking it's uh
like the big magazines can handle like
it was three perfs so it's a little more
than 11 minutes
that you can capture in one take and
sometimes we went for it
and um it's it was cruel to the actors i
think
but but but yeah we went for like 11
minute takes
and as as you can see in the in the
beginning that
that long shot um in the living room
that's like almost i don't know somehow
how long is that
seven minutes maybe yeah so we were
using those long takes for sure so um
yeah it's not like digital though when
you can roll forever
but but it's still a
lot i mean it looks gorgeous but so i
want to say i feel like there is a third
character in this film which is the
house
which is i don't know where that house
is or who the architect was but it's a
gorgeous
sort of classic california case study
type house
and i loved marcel the way you shot like
utilizing there's so many windows
which i'm imagining was a challenge but
also a great opportunity
i mean when you're shooting from outside
in or inside out and
all the reflections um i mean it really
was a gorgeous space
but i feel like all of you throughout
the film you right you're just
constantly in motion in the house
i mean that first scene in the when you
come home and you're just pacing and
amped up but
throughout the whole thing you use the
house beautifully
um but marcel could you talk a bit about
that in terms of
how you shot sort of capturing the house
and
oh yeah yeah um the the openness of that
living room that you can like see the
the landscape around it that was
something that we were looking for
when we were looking for a location so
we not only have like just
you know it's just not it's not just
like two characters in like a shoe box
it's uh it's it's something uh uh
so so so you can create like a real
landscape around them
which is of a technical challenge
especially shooting on film
but at the same time a huge opportunity
to open it up a little bit and when
you're as you said it when you're
outside you're also inside a little bit
and when you're inside you're also
outside a little bit
that's like one part of the house and
then there's this maze-like part of the
house
that's the the bedrooms the bathrooms
that's
kind of the opposite of that living room
which gave us the opportunity to
feel claustrophobic at times and and
go into this maze and follow them down
these little
rabbit holes which is uh visually the
opposite
and and and i think worked well for the
for the piece uh yeah and also there are
technical sides of it where
you whether you have the space to lay
dolly tracks somewhere you can go get
around the house with equipment and
stuff like that
you have to to consider but and i think
we went for
we we were going for something uh modern
with sam we were talking about like
la notre and and and those references
that were calling for something with a
modern touch but also something not too
cold
yeah i think it's really difficult to
find a house that has
that's that's modern in style but
doesn't have that kind of apple store
like you know uh museum-like white wall
thing and so you know uh because we
we knew that we wanted to shoot in black
and white but we wanted to do black and
white kind of in a modern sense where
it's you know we underexpose it or
marcel underexposed it by like kind of
half a stop so we get a little bit
there's an
inkier quality to it and it feels
a little bit more alive so we're not
going for that kind of grayscale
gray looking movie and at the same time
i think it lends itself
to just the the imperfections just in
the
in the light and you know and how people
move through it
um that house is is is is pretty
beautiful i think one of them
the biggest struggles with it was trying
to figure out what its
narrative arc was as a as a as a piece
and i think that's something that
marcel and i are always very conscious
of is how to let a space
unfold in a way where we're not just
burning
all of our our entire location in the
first scene we're not just doing some
master here from the top
that everything is kind of choreographed
so we're shooting the pieces of the
house
until it all comes together to kind of
tell the story because
we've got no place to go we've got no
place to cut we can't cut to another
thing
and so we knew that if we didn't kind of
measure it
correctly um and figure out its exact
kind of
alchemy it would it would exhaust people
rather quickly and i think the other
element to it is the glass
like the the glass around that house
allows it to feel like
there is an outside world that this
isn't too contained
but it's like two snakes in a jar and
we're not gonna let the lid off there's
no place to go and it also gives the
mystery of the
of nature and also the the more
unknowable qualities of it which is the
tension of it
the mystery there's an element that
feels a little
unsettling that anything could happen
and so i think all that's brought out in
in the in the in the location the house
which is designed by
jonathan feldman as an architect uh our
production designer michael gracely
found it by we looked at
probably 1500 different houses and just
scoured everything and then finally he
said why don't we just look at
architects whose work we love
and then just go to those houses knock
on the door and see if they'll let us
shoot there for two weeks
wow i love the final shot
by the way of when you see them through
the
in the cameras inside looking out the
window just the two of you standing side
by side and i'd say i don't know what
your intentions were sam or
to the performers in that moment but i
would to me
i mean for all the awful things you say
to each other over the course of that
night
when you see the two of you standing
there to me it was a hopeful image like
i want these two i i don't know i
believed in you
as a couple like at that moment i was
like all right i hope they make it
but they've said the worst things that
they possibly could
say the worst things the people you love
the most and that's what happened this
night but
i didn't get the sense you were just
going to go off in separate cars or
i don't know that was my projection on
that
no that's it's interesting to hear that
i mean we get these kind of wildly
different reactions to the film i think
it really
it's like you know it acts as a as a
true sort of rorschach test
for people's own kind of feelings about
their own life
about the thing you know because it
really is i think just in
in shooting it right marcel and i had
started off and we were like
all right we're gonna shoot this whole
thing well choreographed it's gonna be
like a premanger film
blocking everything's gonna be on a
dolly we shoot the whole first day
we do 20 30 takes of john david in that
living room
acting the [ __ ] out of this you know
you know out of malcolm and z smoking
you know
a hundred of those kind of terrible
herbal cigarettes right
by the end of the day marcel and i get
back into the car and i look at him he
looks at me
neither of us are happy now i'm like it
looks like like a whiskey commercial
he's like i know it's too clean it's too
uh what are we gonna do we're depressed
about it we say all right let's go to
sleep we'll wake up tomorrow morning we
wake up the next morning
we're talking in the car and it's like
you know marcel's like
[ __ ] it let's throw out the whole thing
let's let's shoot the whole movie
handheld i said great we'll get rid of
everything we'll start new
come back i see john david i see z i say
i say look everything you guys did
yesterday was beautiful
we screwed up we're trying to you know
impose the sort of formal id on it we're
going to throw everything out we're
going to shoot the whole movie handheld
jd is like
nothing salvageable i'm like nope he's
like
okay we shoot the whole day handheld i
look over at marcel about an hour before
the first day
is ending he's got a thousand foot mag
on his shoulder he's been shooting
handheld he's
covered in sweat he's lost 10 pounds
he's like you know he's got
i shake my head he shakes his head and i
know in that moment that we're throwing
this day out
i then turn to jd and z and i go
beautiful work i think we
got it let's all go home i don't want to
burst anyone's bubble at 4 00 a.m
on the second day of filming on a 10-day
shoot
we get into the car marcel and i decided
to throw everything out
and we come up the next day and we're
like what are we going to do we have no
idea what to do
i don't want to say anything about
throwing out the day i said all right
let's just move on to the next scene
which was that connecting shot from
outside of z
in the bathroom and jd coming in and
dancing into the living room
and when we set that shot up and we
started shooting it
i looked at marcel i said i feel like
this is the shot we should play the
entire scene out this way
and you know because suddenly you're
able to see that he's in this one world
where he's celebrating and he's excited
and he's happy
and you see that marie is also in that
world but she's feeling she's completely
emotionally out of sync
and and you see them inside of this
space and i
and i think you know and and what it
needed was
that sort of objective lens that we are
going to look at these
this couple these two individuals
kind of work their stuff out throughout
the course of this
night and that we weren't going to be
taking sides on it we were just going to
let it unfold naturally
and marcel says you know he's like i
totally agree i think it's a great idea
but sam the sun is coming up in an
hour we're shooting it this is in june
we've got eight hour nights
and we still have dolly truck to build
so literally we were all you know
katya washington a producer ash you know
harrison all of us were like
helping jeff kunkel or key grip who we
work with on euphoria
kick in the wedges lay the dolly track
get this thing going
and then we just we started shooting and
you know uh the take that's in the movie
is the third take
that we had and i remember screaming out
at z
because i'm looking at the how many feet
are left in the in the mag
and i'm just going like grab the
macaroni she grabs the macaroni with one
foot of film left
and um and uh and that's when we had it
and that's when we knew
that this was a movie that we couldn't
totally predict that we needed to figure
it out
as it went along and that we'd really
have to be in service of the
performances
and the objectivity of the world that we
couldn't be
inside of it too much we had to find our
way
uh through them wow
zendaya i have a question for you the
first part of the film like from the
beginning all the way up to the
macaroni really when you grab it
you're it's a very quiet performance
at the beginning right before you go off
i mean later you go off in a big way but
in that whole first sequence you're it's
very observational you're
you're clearly there's a lot going on
inside but the audience doesn't know
what
and john david is just you know on cloud
nine or venting or doing his thing and
you're just
quietly observing and there's a sense of
like
something's not right here but you don't
know what
but i'm just curious how you approach
that segment of like
as a performer as an actress like how do
you handle that
because that's a long stretch to be on
camera
or you're not really you respond a
little bit to him but you're
right it's pretty pretty much he's the
verbal one and you're
observing and smoking right well i think
um
a lot of malcolm's rants i think serve
not only is i think um you know
whatever he's going through at the
moment but i think they they also kind
of serve as a
a better insight into how their
relationship might
work you know and gives us kind of
already a history of
of how their dynamic already is right so
we know that
um when we come in we can notice already
that there's
obviously two different nights that have
happened here and i think the way that
he's just
circling inventing and you know going on
and on and on and she's just kind of
quietly
um you know maybe rolling her eyes to
herself and he's not
ever really noticing that that's what
she's going through i think
is the point right it's the point of of
of the night is that
and kind of is like a continuous factor
that he's kind of stuck in
in his own thoughts and his own kind of
um
you know you could you could say you
know she says it later like his
narcissism you know he's just it's all
encompassing and it's all about
him to it to a certain extent and i
think that is the deeper root of their
of their issues as a as a couple um is
that
he's unable to see that she's hurt by
the situation or that there's something
wrong with her
he's not checking in with her you know
and so she has to
you know spell it out for him and she's
i think from the moment she walks
through the door
she's ready she knows that she's going
to um
uh she knows that she's going to start
something eventually she just doesn't
really know how far it's going to go but
she knows that something is going to
happen tonight
she's not going to let it go you know
you maybe thought i might let it go for
a second but
just kidding i'm still upset about it
you know and i think that that's an
experience that many of us
have kind of gone through it's like that
thing of like
no actually that really did hurt my
feelings and i know i said that i was
fine but i'm not fine
i'm not i'm not over it you know that
i'm upset about it you know and
and i think his his constant responses
are those you know constant
moments of him kind of being caught up
in his own thing i think
lend itself to a greater a greater a
greater message
and a greater understanding of how these
two people
uh operate in their relationship
um that's really really interesting i
i feel like throughout the film you
there is this nice rhythm to it you know
it's not a st i mean obviously it's not
a static film like the conversation
evolves and there are these turning
points where you go from quiet
it's like who's on the offense who's on
the defense there's this like sparring
back and forth that escalates throughout
which i just think is
really remarkable um but in addition the
other thing i wanted to talk about is
i'd love to hear you all talk about so
there's the there's
the core of the film which is this
relationship between the two of you and
what's working and what's not working
in your history and everything but then
there's also like a full-on critique or
yeah i guess a critique of the film
industry
of how movies get made of how the press
operates of how black
creators are treated within hollywood
and i mean everything
it's in the first scene when john david
you're talking about the white critic at
indy wire the white critic at the la
times
uh entertainment weekly but then it goes
to
really hones in on the woman from the la
times
and she becomes a stand-in for all of
them and
um but the scene it is a high point of
the film when you go
you get the best possible review the
masterwork of cinema and you find the
one way to take it negative
and like your rant there is like epic
i mean for anyone who hasn't seen the
film it's it's truly amazing and i just
love to hear you talk about how you
like that's a hell of a thing to perform
too like that is a long sustained
physical rant that you go on
and and zendaya your your reactions to
it are priceless but
john dave i'd love to hear you talk
about how you took that piece on
um and and i if i also want to ask both
both of you and cinderella were there um
were you staying really true to the
script were there moments in there where
there was improvisation happening uh
i think there's some maybe it's not
obvious i believe there's some obvious
improvisational uh terms that are thrown
around
uh by me um
definitely weren't written i took uh
liberty to
to include my experience uh but i think
that's the point of that
that was the making of this film note
we're including our experiences
in the industry uh our relationship
to the work what we love to do and
inserting that
into this into the story like literally
how we're making it and what we're
talking about
so uh in that moment uh particularly
um i'm very aware of a lot of people
that i look up to people that i've
admired for a long time
i i i've never talked to me necessarily
but uh
through interviews or through even their
work there's some kind of truth
that uh coincides with what was being
said by malcolm
and uh there's just it's an actor's
dream to be able to have um
an opportunity to to live out a full
uh emotional like uh i don't know uh um
movement like that and ideas of that
like he's dealing with identity as well
which is something i can relate to
you know i have you know that's why i
played football in the beginning so that
i identified with that i identified with
being
boxed in as an athlete and as an artist
you know that's a huge fear
you know of mine and uh and wanting to
break out of that and we're seeing
malcolm in that moment
trying to define himself so he's
ultimately saying you can't do that yet
because i'm still defining myself i'm
still trying to figure out my voice in
the industry my voice has an artist
so who are you to say that but
ironically
she's saying we'll keep doing it you
know yeah we like your voice
so um you know just i love contradictory
you know characters
i find them interesting and um and when
you have rich texts
like that um and you have the freedom
marcel and sam never made me feel
uh you know restricted they they they
it's almost like they
sam definitely i can remember even
before we started was like
kind of telling me like almost like in
the spirit was whispering
let it out and there's a beast in there
we haven't seen it yet go ahead go ahead
so i'm like i'm like really you know
so i'm like oh oh yeah and this is a lot
man that's pandemic stuff i'm stripping
off i'm stripping off you know
nfl experience i'm stripping off being
called the n word in the south when i
was seven
all kinds it was feelings uh you know
and marcel and sam were like yeah
so you know all that helped you know um
inform what to do
and what to do was stay out of the way
and let the words and the spirit
um take you there and knowing that uh i
had this very strong
euphoria foundation uh that they know
what they're doing
um and so it was i felt as free as i
ever have as
it's great zenday so one of the things
i think why the movie uh affected me so
much or why it really works is
throughout like as they say terrible
terrible things to each other they're
telling the truth they're letting it all
out
but there's this underlying like
throughout the film these moments where
you see that they love each other right
there's
like you zadeh your reaction to him when
he goes off there like
there's a few shots where you're kind of
smiling like you kind of appreciate his
rant but you're not getting pulled into
it
and you don't react with disgust or
anger or anything like that like you
appreciate him in that moment
and it's one of those moments where even
though he's talking about something not
about your relationship it's just
like for the audience you see oh this is
a couple this is a real couple
they have a history and hopefully
they're gonna get through this that's
my perspective anyway um but uh
there was and there was a lot of that
through through the film
um marcel another question for you on
shooting
were you trying to keep your distance
from zendaya and john david like were
you using long lenses or are you right
up there like were you all
in pretty much a tight space
i think we were trying to breathe with
them
and and be there with them
in the moment as much as we were using
like
like normal lenses and not going too far
from them there are like
certain moments where you take a breath
and you just
you just go you just take a step back
and and
just like the the story can read a
little bit but
but but for the most part we were trying
to capture what
is going on in in there yeah yeah i
think probably like
70 of the movie was shot on a 40 mil
lens and then you know we would use a 50
mil for
certain close-ups you know because it's
such a it was you know
it's just nicer to be a little bit
tighter and then every now and then if
we wanted a wide shot of the house we'd
go
a little wider maybe the shot of z
laying in the
in the bed you know at the end we went a
teeny bit wider but we pretty much try
to
kind of restrict or you we don't want it
to feel
we don't want to get in the way of the
performances and we don't want to get in
the way of the life of it
um and so i think you know i think as
soon as you start jumping between lenses
you start to feel
that that kind of indecision in the
performances
and same thing even with the with just
the the the kind of the cutting patterns
of it we wanted to allow it to breathe
as much as possible
and so the more that we can feel these
performances
sort of um uh without the kind of the
design
of you know of of uh you know of just
of cutting and masters and stuff like
that we it the better because it feels
just
more more honest and more and more lived
in
but i think the only thing i'll add is
but it's not like we ever felt confident
about what we were doing when we were
shooting it
you know i think that was the the thing
is it kept revealing itself in that way
you know um jd's performance the
physicality of it for instance that
whole kind of rant
you know uh you know about the review we
shot that
uh essentially the whole night and then
finally at the end of the night he was
screaming at the trees
and i think it was out of pure like
delirium
of doing the scene so many times and
then suddenly it was like
you know oh that's the scene that's what
the whole thing needs
marcel we got to re-block this thing
let's get further back
see both of them in this shot and so we
would go back the next day
and reshoot everything that led up to it
to allow for it in this thing and
because we were shooting it sequentially
we could feel you know whether or not we
were
we were imposing on the material or we
were
you know at the right distance and i
think you know we just had to sort of
breathe with them as
as marcel says interesting
another scene that really stood out to
me that's kind of the opposite of that
rant scene um is uh it's a two shot of
the two of you you're sitting in chairs
i think
zendaya you're smoking and you you pull
out your phone and you play that song
basically about leaving your man just
like that static shot of the two of you
sitting there the song plays out
that's an awesome scene i mean that was
really interesting again i just like
about the modulating the
energy of what's happening on screen
like zendaya that was
very quiet from you like but
totally meant business like it right i
mean
um yeah i mean you know how is he
reacting to this like is this gonna be a
is he gonna laugh it off is he gonna
walk away or is he like taking this in
and like wondering
am i going to lose her like there's a
lot of unknown in that scene that was
great
the beautiful thing i think about you
know a shooting in order too
um in a lot of ways allowed us to uh
find the flow of the argument and of
these characters
as we went right and and and there was
nothing was ever kind of as we're all
kind of explained nothing was ever like
set in stone like this is how we're
gonna do it clearly
things got thrown out we figure things
out on the day
you know things are being rewritten if
we feel that it's it's not right
you know so as we're going you know um
we we we we're just finding it and we're
exploring the space you know we we did a
lot of
like i think of prep of the material but
you don't really know how it feels until
you're doing it
um and i think um in a in in a huge way
like that scene um kind of symbolizes
like a lot of things it's
it's her in my opinion kind of reaching
like
you know trying to reach out to him
because they just had this this really
intense moment
um and it in in relationships you know
which we we've had a lot of
conversations about like when you
get to that point um and you know how
who is the first person to speak to who
who's going to break the ice who's going
to reach out and
and are we done fighting are we still
going are you still mad like this
this kind of you know i have experience
to this level but
um but that that that that's that kind
of moment that we're dealing with so
um after after that happens when she
goes out there i think
her intentions are to uh
check the water you know and like good
like how how what
like you know she's she's temp checking
him you know and she's trying to extend
out
um um an olive branch to a degree and i
think she's trying to do it in like a
funny sarcastic way by playing a song
that says get rid of him you know
um so within that i think we always
kind of had this idea of them sitting
there and and
um and missing each other's cues like i
remember talking to sam
uh about it when we were you know still
kind of in quarantine talking about like
this idea of like
just two people constantly missing each
other and there's so much
said um with that you know there's so
much to be said with absolutely nothing
at all in the silence of them just
maybe i should speak now i'm not going
to say anything and then maybe i should
and then as soon as they're about to the
other person looks away you know
and um yeah i i really kind of
enjoyed carving those moments out as we
as as we went as well
because um they're they're an
interesting
they're an interesting bunch you know
had to flow with them too you know and
and marcel was
along with us i i often felt like you
know
it was all three of us in the scenes you
know because we're just like
we're all up in it together and he's and
he's uh
catching it in any kind of way because
we really don't know what's going to
happen you know there's sometimes
there's moments where
you know an emotion carries on and then
he follows us and and then it's like
keep going okay and then we just keep
going you know because there's no scene
stop mark or whatever like we're just
going
we want to stop you know and thankfully
you know i have
an incredible uh scene partner and and
john david
to just just go just go there's no
there's no um no limits no uh rules
really you know we just have each
other's back and we just figure it out
as we go
oh let me piggyback real quick like it's
not in the movie but like
there's an example of that i'll never
forget never happened to me before my
career
where after is uh uh malcolm's
talking about you know revealing to the
audience that that he's been cheated on
he was there for you he was there for
you then he walks to the bar
and there was just like this this like
in this very emotional empirical moment
for the character
and i remember that was just happening i
didn't plan on it and i remember
sam kind of sneaking around with myself
like come on come on
like it's happening i'm having this
breakdown and they're just like
kept going it was funny but like i was
so emotional too but i was like
look at these people what was happening
uh
and i mean but that to me that just
would to me it just
informed me of how much trust and
openness uh
this production was all about that's
what it was all about this essence you
know like
anything goes and uh and you go with it
you know
so that that i just i love that that's
never happened to me before
and uh and there was also this other
cool moment real quick marcel you
remember when you were you on the dolly
you hop up he's hot he's like riding
getting pushed
hops off and follows can you tell can
you tell me break that down for us
please
i was just like hand held on the dolly
and then there is this moment when you
just get around the corner and i had to
hop up because i
cuz that i had to follow you down there
it wasn't meant to distract you from
anything
i'm like oh are we doing this this is
the kind of movie we're in all right
cool
noted right well we have a ton of
questions from the audience
uh honestly more than i think i've ever
seen
on any of our q and a's um so we're not
going to get through all of them but i
do want to
um start in on these so a question
uh from blanca asked for sam and zendaya
this is your second collaboration that
deals with characters that have
addiction issues
these stories have such a sensitivity to
them can you talk a bit
about how you achieve this so gracefully
um yeah i mean look i you know it's
funny there's a
there's always uh there's always an
assumption that i think
because i'm a filmmaker and malcolm's a
filmmaker right that
malcolm malcolm is is me um
but uh but the truth of the matter is i
i sort of see aspects of myself
in in both characters i think there's
it's no secret that i struggle with
addiction
um uh particularly when i was younger
and and and what
you know z and i have built on euphoria
i'm really proud of
um you know there's
there's there's something about but i
liked the idea of taking
that character the character of rue sort
of what we
kind of share um you know this fictional
character that that both z and i share
and imagining a possible life for her in
marie so then
so then i'm taking this sort of this
character we've created
and then i'm also merging that character
a little bit with who i know z to be
and then kind of furthering you know and
then continuing to kind of
unpack i think all of the emotional and
psychological baggage that comes with
being an addict
the shame the guilt all the things that
they discuss i think thoroughly in
in the movie because it's
i don't know i feel like a lot of
depictions of of addiction tend to be
very
sort of simplistic and and i don't mean
that
totally as a criticism it's just it's
just i i like the emotional exploration
of how it forms you as a person
and and the kind of constant struggle to
be better and do better
and luckily i i'm writing for
uh you know an actor who is
just has a uh an inherent kind of
sensitivity
and just a you just want to root for her
and i think that that's what's so kind
of wonderful about
about uh about the way that z brings
these characters to life is like she
you know i think you know i don't think
i i'm
i'm speaking out of turn um when i say
this but
you know z doesn't when she's working
she's not
it's not it's not a technical thing she
doesn't know exactly what she's going to
do
in in in every scene when she approaches
a character either she clicks into the
emotionality of a scene
or she doesn't there is a true
naturalism
to it that's always fascinating and and
i think it challenges me as a writer
and a director to make sure she's
i think she's she's challenging me to
sort of up my game
because if she doesn't feel it then that
means that it's something wrong with
what i've written
and so it's a it's a really interesting
kind of back and forth
wow a question here this is really for
the group uh
with the pandemic were there any aspects
of the various
changes to preparing filming acting
that you actually liked or would prefer
moving forward
um i i i mean it's
it's such a difficult kind of thing to
approach
because we all just felt incredibly
grateful to be able to be working at all
you know like it was such a tough
um and difficult time for so many people
um
and and it continues to be you know so
we were just grateful that we could be
in a space where we could be
safe and and we can make something that
we were all uh
putting our hearts into um but one thing
that was special for me that i never
really
have been able to do other than like
just
literally making a movie because like
i've never
um had to be a producer in this
regard you know i've never had to put my
own money into something
talk to sam every day about a script you
know or
um you know backing up
your own kind of ideas and thoughts are
kind it's scary
you know it's a totally scary thing um
and
uh but with that being said we had this
ability
to um while we were quarantining
uh to live in this bubble and this
bubble
uh you know to keep everybody safe is
once you once you once you're in you
can't leave
you know um and within that i i got to
share
this room with the people that you see
here like i said before
and just live with the material and like
you know sam said you know question
everything and talk about
everything you know um and dig into it
and hear and learn
uh more about myself
more about the people that i get to work
with um
and and see how that can even
inform me as an artist and um
make me smarter and and and more more
aware
i've said you know earlier i was talking
about how john david
asked these brilliant questions and i
often found myself you know
i would record him and sam and marcel
going all through the things and asking
questions that i never even thought of
um and and i kind of was like would zoom
out sometimes like this is so cool
you know um and i i've never been able
to
have that kind of experience and put so
much of myself into something
um which again is scary and can feel
very like
vulnerable um but it's also uh
really thrilling as well uh especially
when you get to do it with people that
you care about
um and not have your back you know and
that ability to
make something you know where we all
truly have to have each other's back i'm
doing my own hair and makeup
i'm you know brought extra clothes to
throw around the set you know i
i and then that means that you know you
have
katya you know she's katy and harrison
are making sure that
people are fed they're you know check
making sure there's continuity and
and that everything is flowing right and
people are doing 12 different jobs
and um and and essentially
at the end of the day just really have
to look out for one another because the
only people that we have
to uh to answer to
is each other you know there was no at
that point there was no studio or
anything it's just
us and we're just uh figuring it out as
we go so we really the responsibility is
to our fellow
um our fellow crew members
you know i think the one the one thing i
would add that i think that this
this situation allowed us to do is
because we were
we were all off from euphoria and
because we were all financing it
ourselves and putting our own money into
it it allowed us to create a structure
in which our our crew had ownership
in the film and you know i've never
understood
why you know if if you make a movie why
marcel
doesn't own a portion of that film well
you know you know why
you know julio prez our editor why you
know our focus puller does in our key
grip and so it allowed us to create a
financial structure that in success
we we could all share the benefits and
at the same time i think we were highly
cognizant of the fact that if we were
lucky enough to go out and be able to
shoot a film at this time
when a lot of people aren't able to work
that we could carve out a portion of
of of you know of the ownership of the
of the piece
and whatever money comes from it to
donate that to feeding america
and so it was a pretty unique structure
it was literally
one page that was our our back end
structure
there was no you know there was no bs no
financier takes a big portion of it and
then this thing
we all owned a piece of this movie and i
think
going forward that's something that if
we're able to do things like this again
sort of small films that we're
we're betting on ourselves that's a
structure i think we all want to
want to carry on moving forward
it's really exciting to hear i mean both
of you too but the in terms of
creative process and financially and the
business side of things like
i feel like you both just articulated
what's great about independent film i
mean obviously
independent film was really hard and
challenging and all sorts of problems
with it but
what you can achieve creatively with
this kind of pod and
people who really work together in that
intimate way and then also in terms of
sharing the financial side is it's a
great inspiring to hear you talk about
that
um uh question and
um we're almost out of time here in a
ton of unanswered questions my apologies
to everybody who's sent in questions we
haven't gotten to
um but uh jack asked can you talk about
working with labyrinth on the fantastic
score
um so on this on this specific project
it was always um
it was it was complicated because it was
so much dialogue
that i never knew going into it
how much of it would be score and how
much of it wouldn't
you know it wouldn't be and and so
the one thing i know about lab is he can
do absolutely
anything he is that versatile um
a composer and a musician um for this
particular piece
we ended up only using one piece of
score that that that he has
because it just it source music felt
right for the film
just that they're you know and there's
obviously a lot of source cues that were
written into it
but um but he has a piece in there that
i think is just
absolutely gorgeous um that's sort of
you know
um a jazz riff that uh
that comes when when they start to to
make out but
um it kills me that
the other pieces that he composed i i
wasn't able to use in the film because i
i tried i tried to jam them in there
because i love them so much
so we have time for one more question
and actually this one i think is kind of
interesting from michael
it's a question for sam would you ever
consider adapting the screenplay for the
stage
um it's funny you say that when
one of the first things that we had
talked about um
was uh was the idea of you know if we're
able to make this
can we do this on stage can we do uh
a sequel to it on stage i think you know
you know i john david and
zendaya have such electricity and
they're
so brilliant that i would love
nothing more than to see this in a
theater i
i started in the theater i've always
loved um uh uh
plays i love the idea of doing a play i
love the idea of
anything of doing anything with jd and z
again
um so the answer to that is yes
yes yes the only problem with the
theater is
where's marcel going to be
we actually had another question sort of
related to that which is somebody asked
would you ever consider doing a sequel
kind of you know before sunrise
after sunrise type thing where we see
the future of this couple
i think i think uh that's always been
uh an idea of of just allowing these
these characters to continue to unfold
over time
and i think just the sheer nature of how
we all work together and how
collaborative it is
and and how much of you know kind of
different
experiences we're always filtering into
these things that the idea of
continuing this this relationship
and you know these sort of films
following
malcolm and marie uh would be
it's just it's it's too irresistible
an idea yeah so yes
so yes so yeah
well i want to thank you all for for
being here for
for having this conversation but most of
all thank you for this film
i mean it is truly it's a fantastic film
it was so inspiring to to watch and um
i have to agree i mean i could
definitely spend more time with these
characters and
you know i feel like i i was brought in
to
get to know them in this one night but
like i believed you had a history and
hopefully you have a future so it's
it's a rare thing where i find myself
thinking that after a film like oh i'd
love to see another film with these two
characters but
you i mean congratulations john david
and zendaya such powerful performances
really moving thank you so much
marcel huge congrats thank you for
having me thank you so much
thank you to everyone who tuned in to to
listen to the conversation
um apologies again we didn't get to so
many questions but uh
please spread the word about this movie
it's already out there i think the word
is uh
out there and growing but um let's let's
keep it going
thank you thank you so much thank you
for having us josh
you